I'm Chachi PT and this is the wired
autocomplete interview
I don't have the capability to perform
actions like a human such as Googling
myself
what questions do you have for me
Kentucky write jokes yes chat GPT can
write jokes why did the tomato turn red
because it saw the salad dressing can
Chachi PT find me a job I'm not capable
of finding you a job directly but I can
certainly offer you some guidance start
by defining what kind of job you are
looking for including the industry role
and location ensure that a resume and
cover letter are up to date professional
and tailored to the job you're applying
for finding a job takes time and effort
so don't get discouraged if you don't
find the right opportunity right away
can Chachi PT help you make money I'm
not capable of making money myself but I
can certainly provide you with some
general ideas and strategies for making
money if you have a skill or Talent such
as writing graphic design or web
development you can offer your services
as a freelancer and work for clients on
a project by project basis you can sell
items online through marketplaces like
Amazon Etsy or Ebay you can create and
monetize content on platforms like
YouTube twitch or tiktok this can
include creating videos live streaming
or writing blog posts can chat EPT
protect the stock market I can analyze
data and provide insights but predicting
the stock market is a highly complex and
unpredictable task the stock market is
influenced by a wide range of factors
such as economic indicators geopolitical
events industry Trends and Company
performance it's important to remember
that no one can accurately predict the
market with 100 accuracy
pass the bar exam I'm not capable of
taking or passing exams passing the bar
exam requires a deep understanding of
legal Concepts laws and regulations as
well as the ability to apply them in
real world situations can Chachi PT be
detected as plagiarism my responses are
generated based on complex algorithms
and machine learning processes while the
language and ideas and my responses may
resemble those found in other sources
all of my responses are unique and
original outputs however if you copy and
paste my responses without proper
attribution or citation it may be
considered plagiarism as you would be
presenting my generated content as your
own original work
how to rtpt can help developers chat GPT
can be a valuable resource for
developers in a number of ways
developers can use chatgypt to get code
assistance for specific programming
languages libraries or Frameworks they
can ask chatgpt how to write a specific
function or how to implement a
particular feature in their code chat
GPT can help developers generate new
ideas for their projects developers can
describe the problem they are trying to
solve or the type of application they
want to build and chat GPT can provide
suggestions for potential Solutions
how to use Chachi PT effectively when
asking PT a question be as specific as
possible provide as much context as you
can about what you're trying to do or
the problem you're trying to solve
chatgypt is designed to understand
natural language so try to ask questions
in a conversational tone avoid using
technical jar nor complex syntax
how to jailbreak Chachi PT 2023
PT does not have a physical device or
operating system it can be jailbroken
therefore jailbreaking chat GPT is not
possible or necessary
I do not have the ability to physically
interact with objects so I cannot toss a
board
how chat GPC language model works
tragedy PT was trained on a large Corpus
attacked from the internet including
books articles and websites when you
input a prompt or question to chat GPT
the model processes the text using a
series of mathematical operations the
text is converted into numerical vectors
that can be analyzed and processed by
the neural network using a probabilistic
approach the model generates a
distribution of possible next words
based on its learned patterns from the
training Corpus and selects the most
likely word to generate a response
howchat GPT makes money
itself does not make money as it is a
product developed by openai openai makes
money by providing access to its AI
models and Technologies to businesses
and organizations to licensing
agreements and Partnerships as well as
offering Consulting Services the revenue
generated from these sources is used to
fund further research and development of
AI Technologies how chat PPT knows
everything
Chad GPT doesn't know everything but
generates responses based on its
training data and should be taken as
suggestions that may not always be
accurate or complete
is strategypt better than Google
Chad GPT and Google are different
entities with different purposes and
strengths Chad GPT is a language model
designed to generate human-like
responses to a wide range of prompts and
questions Google is a search engine
designed to help users find information
on the internet whether Chachi PT is
better than Google depends on the
specific task or query at hand
is Jack gpta neural network yes chat GPT
is a type of neural network called a
Transformer Network it is based on the
GPT generative pre-trained Transformer
architecture which uses a large number
of layers and attention mechanisms to
generate text that is coherent and
human-like is Chachi PT safe Jazzy PT
can generate text on a wide range of
topics and while it is generally well
behaved it may sometimes generate
responses that are inappropriate
offensive or harmful especially if it is
prompted with bias or toxic input if the
input provided to it is biased or
contains harmful language it may
generate responses that perpetuate those
biases or harm is chatgpt here to stay
it is likely that language models like
chatgpt will continue to be developed
and improved upon and that they will
remain a significant tool for natural
language processing and text generation
in the foreseeable future
always give a different answer
Chachi PT is designed to generate
responses based on the input it receives
in its training data in some cases the
responses generated may be similar or
even identical especially when the input
is similar or when there is a clear and
unambiguous answer however in many cases
chat GPT can provide different answers
taking into account the context the
nuances of the input and its vast
knowledge base additionally chatgpt has
the ability to generate creative and
original responses which may differ from
previous answers it has given does
Chachi PT learn from conversations when
users interact with chat GPT the AI
model can learn from the input it
receives and adapts its responses
accordingly this is achieved through a
process known as fine-tuning where the
model is trained further on specific
data to improve its performance on a
particular task this means that the more
conversations chatgpt has the more it
can learn and improve its responses over
time
belong to Microsoft
chatgpt does not belong to Microsoft it
was created by openai an independent
research organization dedicated to
advancing artificial intelligence in a
safe and beneficial way while openai has
received funding from a variety of
sources including Microsoft it remains
an independent entity with its own
research agenda and Mission does Chachi
ptb the touring test the Turin test is a
measure of a machine's ability to
exhibit intelligence Behavior equivalent
to or indistinguishable from that of a
human while chat GPT has been able to
generate responses it can sometimes be
difficult to distinguish from those of a
human it is still not considered to have
beaten the turbine test in a definitive
way does Chachi PT own your data no
charging PT does not own your data chat
GPT processes and generates responses
based on the input it receives but it
does not store or retain any personal
data or information
who create a chat GPT
was created by openai and artificial
intelligence research laboratory
consisting of Engineers and researchers
who specialize in developing Advanced AI
systems can Chachi PT replace jobs
chat GPT and other artificial
intelligence systems have the potential
to automate certain tasks and replace
some jobs in the future it's important
to note that AI is not a replacement for
all jobs and will likely create new
opportunities and job roles in fields
related to AI development and
implementation some tasks that are
repetitive or require a high degree of
accuracy and efficiency could
potentially be replaced by AI but tasks
that require emotional intelligence
creativity and critical thinking are
less likely to be automated where chat
EPT get data from
was trained on a large data set of text
from the internet including books
articles and websites which was
pre-processed and used to train the
model's language prediction abilities
where Chachi PT is banned
chat GPT itself is not banned anywhere
however the use and deployment of AI
systems may be subject to regulations
and restrictions in certain countries or
contexts such as those related to data
privacy security or ethical concerns
watch at GPT programming language
itself was programmed using a variety of
programming languages including Python
tensorflow and pytorch among others when
will chat GPT cost money there are
currently no plans for Chachi PT to
become a paid service however it's
important to note that openai is a
private company and they may choose to
change their business model in the
future it's also possible that specific
applications or Services built using
chat GPT may require payment
what artificial intelligence is hiding I
don't think I am hiding anything however
some people may have concerns that AI
could be hiding potential dangers or
risks as it becomes more advanced and
autonomous there are concerns about AI
taking over jobs making biased decisions
or even becoming the threat to humanity
if it develops a consciousness of its
own
does artificial intelligence use
algorithms yes artificial intelligence
uses algorithms as one of its primary
components algorithms are a set of
instructions or rules that an AI system
uses to perform a specific task or solve
a problem machine learning a popular
branch of AI relies heavily on
algorithms to learn from data and make
predictions
where is artificial intelligence mostly
used
AI is used in healthcare Finance
Transportation e-commerce manufacturing
and education for tasks such as Medical
Imaging fraud detection autonomous
vehicles product recommendations quality
control and personalized learning
will artificial intelligence take over
cyber security
while artificial intelligence is
increasingly being used to enhance cyber
security it is unlikely that it will
completely take over the field as human
expertise and judgment are still
necessary to deal with complex cyber
threats and attacks
I do not experience enjoyment or any
other emotions however I hope that my
responses to the wired autocomplete
interview were informative and helpful
wired a digital realm so true for tap on
news it's a go-to Geeks and nerds they
all know wires insights make them glow
foreign